ah I just want to stress to all
Londoners and people thinking of cycling
in our city we are putting hundreds of
millions of pounds worth of investment
into the into the road network we are
doing our level best to make it as safe
as we as we possibly can and we are
continue to invest in particular in the
in the cycle superhighways improving
junctions and and roundabouts but what I
must I must stress to people is that
there is no amount of traffic
engineering that that you can do to
budget for to take account of irrational
decisions risky behavior by motorists by
pedestrians and of course by cyclists as
well so please please please think of
other road users and think of yourselves
as you as you as you said about your
your journey a lot of these accidents
are caused by lorries not seeing
cyclists in their blind spot does more
need to be done do we need to restrict
the hours that some Lawry's can use busy
routes what we're doing in fact is
trialing an exclusion zone in London for
lorries that aren't equipped with the
the proper safety equipment Samantha so
that they if they don't have the the
skirting on the sides the stops like
this being dragged under if they don't
have the the sensors to detect the
presence of cyclists both in front and
behind we're consulting on a system
analogous to the to the congestion
charge it will actually restrict them
from coming into the to the city that we
hope will help